we begin this morning with breaking news
overnight of significant progress in the
deadliest wildfires in California
history but the battle is far from over
new body camera footage shows a
sheriff's deputy braving the flames to
rescue a disabled woman and to get
people to flee to safety
the good news may be short-lived
firefighters are bracing for more dry
and windy weather today the fires have
killed at least 35 people and forced
more than 90,000 residents from their
homes more than 5,700 homes and
buildings have been destroyed Carter
Evans is in Santa Rosa with the latest
on the fire Carter good morning good
morning the fire wiped out entire
neighborhoods like this one and this is
what thousands of people are going to
find when they're finally allowed to
return home you know the fire storm
raged through town in the middle of the
night and many people had little or no
warning at all
dramatic body camera video shows the
danger Sonoma County sheriff's deputies
faced driving through the flames in a
desperate effort to evacuate as many
people as possible even loading a woman
into the back of a patrol car Sonoma
County Sheriff Rob Giordano says it's
important for people to see this video
I gotta get people to understand that
this is a dangerous event it is not over
stay away from the houses and understand
the severity of what this fire can do
more than 9,000 firefighters are trying
to contain the flames which have already
sports an area larger than New York City
and high winds expected this weekend
could reignite the danger the trees and
everything on this edge were fire that
tree was on fire James Whitfield fought
the flames himself as they raced toward
his home in Santa Rosa how fast did this
all go up pretty quick I would say with
him you know three or four minutes this
fire was already starting to get up back
to where we're standing his home was
spared but not his barn
his wife Alicia tried to salvage what
she could we're just glad that you know
we could and then we could get out
because I know there's people that
haven't couldn't the death toll from the
fires continues to rise Friday crews
dressed in protective suits searched for
the missing with cadaver dogs we are all
humans you know everybody cares about
this and it does impact us we're not
gonna grow up selves a time limit but
we're gonna find every missing person
that that's gets reported now
authorities say it could be weeks before
they determine the actual cause of the
fire searching for the cause is a
process they describe as painstaking
because a lot of the evidence was burned
that's forcing them Alex to search for
other clues tragic situation out there
Carter Evans in Santa Rosa California
thanks Carter